moi il y a une chose qui me gêne un peu
ici vous voyez c'est le bruit des
voitures les les échappements là ça vous
aime pas on en a tellement on était le
boulevard Charles de Gaulle à Colombes
alors vous savez
[Musique]
ça
où le dimanche et les jours de fête où
aller quand on est saturé de l'air de la
ville et que l'on a la chance d'avoir un
moyen de transport bien à soi ou mais à
la campagne tout bêtement
avant d'atteindre l'endroit rêvé il faut
souffrir un peu sur la route car on est
pas seul
d'autres aussi vont à la campagne et au
fond n'est-ce pas le côté réconfortant
de notre époque tout ce qui fait que
l'on n'est jamais seul tout ce qui rend
la vie collective si agréable
vous venez souvent dans le coin ici
madame
comment ça racontez-moi tous les samedis
on fait les marchés puis on vient le
déjeuner ici comment vous faites le
marché vous vous avez un stand dans un
marché c'est ça qu'est-ce que vous
vendez
ensuite à Paris
[Musique]
mais pourquoi je pouvais en bordure de
route comme ça
vous aimeriez pas mieux aller dans un
coin plus tranquille non c'est toi aussi
bien là ça vous gêne pas ce passage de
voiture
oui mais vous croyez pas que quand vous
avez bien travaillé là vous avez fini
votre marché ce serait agréable de
rester dans un coin tranquille oui
d'accord on a pas le temps de ça juste
pour déjeuner il y en a pas le temps de
se reposer trop longtemps
ça vous amuse de voir passer les
voitures comme ça
vous venez souvent le dimanche ici
oui nous nous sommes habitués au coin et
c'est en principe la deuxième fois qu'on
vient cette année je vais étant donné
que le temps n'est pas favorable c'est
seulement la deuxième fois mais on vient
assez régulièrement ici toujours pas
particulièrement ce coin ici on est venu
là parce que ça plaise à ma femme vu
qu'il étant donné qu'il y avait du
soleil
et moi je n'aime pas le soleil
vous habitez Paris non n'habite Paris
oui un quartier aéré de 18e
[Musique]
un bol d'air mais vous croyez pas qu'il
y a des coins plus agréables que ce bord
de route ici
oui étant donné que je précise bien ma
femme aurait préféré le soleil nous
sommes venus ici étant donné qu'il y a
du soleil moi j'avais trouvé un petit
coin dans le bois mais
étant donné que c'était ombragé et puis
c'était déjà pris
[Musique]
il y a beaucoup de monde qui viennent là
le dimanche et c'est comme c'est pris on
est arrivé un peu tard
vous
sortez presque pas
j'aime pas la circulation pour
homme alors justement pourquoi puisque
vous n'avez pas la circulation vous
mettez vous ici en bordure d'une route
il y a pas de place et la forêt elle est
trop dense elle est trop touffu
vous avez vu être à l'heure
[Musique]
pourquoi
il y a pas de place
il y a pas de soleil
vous habitez à quartier aéré à Paris
[Musique]
c'est une joie de venir ici le dimanche
ça vous gêne pas de déjeuner ici avec
tout ce bruit un petit peu
[Musique]
c'est quand même mieux que Paris
qu'est-ce qui prépare leur pas quand
vous partez comme ça
et ça demande beaucoup de travail ça non
du travail
j'habiterai travailler voilà mais ici
vous mangez de meilleur appétit non
on a l'impression
que d'habitude
[Musique]
vous sortez tous les dimanches
il fait beau
et vous venez toujours par ici ou bien
vous changer de quoi
on est bien puis c'est pas loin de chez
nous
moi il y a une chose qui me gêne un peu
ici vous voyez c'est le bruit des
voitures les les échappements là ça vous
aime pas on en a tellement nous on
essaie de boulevard Charles de Gaulle à
Colombes
alors vous savez
ça ici au contraire on en a moins de
bruit pour nous vous n'aimeriez pas
mieux aller dans un coin plus tranquille
que ça à l'intérieur de la forêt tout à
l'heure on a essayé toutes les places en
brise
pour venir de bonheur de bonheur
[Musique]
alors c'est plus pareil
sur vos enfants
jouer au boulot
c'est sûr
vous sortez tous les dimanches monsieur
oui pratiquement vous habitez où
donc vous habitez à quoi aérer
ici
parce que c'est mieux que chez nous
quand même c'est
on mange bien on est plus détendu et
Madame
j'aimerais bien savoir ce qu'elle pense
[Musique]
très bien
que la maison les meilleurs appétit ici
alors comme ça le dimanche vous emmener
votre femme et vos enfants à la campagne
à la campagne c'est beaucoup dur enfin
pas trop loin
et justement une question que je voulais
vous poser pourquoi vous mettez vous en
bordure d'une route nationale comme ça
bien écoutez très franchement on revient
un peu du centre du bois il y a
tellement de moustiques qu'on a préféré
revenir au bord il y a plein de petits
bac à côté là
ici ce bruit ces allées venus ça vous
gêne pas trop non
personnellement j'y suis habitué je suis
habite en Colombes en étant en bordure
d'une route nationale où il y a beaucoup
de bruit on s'y fait vous restez ici
jusqu'à quelle heure d'habitude
en rentrant si possible
[Musique]